[Musique]
je m'appelle harmonie voisins j'ai 32
ans je dirige la brasserie la voisine
qui est située à coignières et je
travaille dans cet ordre à s'y colle mon
activité consiste fabriquer de la bière
donc je travaille le malt d'orge de
houblon et l'eau et je transforme tout
ça on dire moi je produis à coignières
donc j'ai mon local qui fait 100 mètres
carrés où toutes mes cuves sont
installés je fabrique sur place je vends
sur place et je vends que localement en
termes d'organisation moi je brasse deux
jours par semaine
après une fois par semaine forcément
faut que je mette en bouteille les
bières et puis après il ya tout le
conditionnement donc l'étiquetage des
bières la mise en carton et puis après
pages livres mais professionnels voilà
tout ce qui est bar-restaurant caviste
magasin de produits bio de produits
locaux
et puis je travaille aussi avec les
particuliers puisque je fais des marchés
tous les dimanches matin
[Musique]
alors la bière parce que déjà la base
moi j'aime bien la voir donc l'idée
c'était de voilà si c'était possible de
le produire à petite échelle et on y
fait c'est possible donc c'est vraiment
agréable c'est le do it yourself fois
c'est fait votre produit consommé l'eau
ça c'est un aspect qui me plaît beaucoup
[Musique]
l'entrepreneuriat c'est vraiment
beaucoup d'indépendance pouvoir prendre
cette décision soit même et voilà
avancer à son rythme et voilà je me sens
libre aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai plaisir de venir tous les
jours à la brasserie cette année c'est
vrai qu'avec cette perspective de
réouverture des bars et des restaurants
je pense que vraiment l'activité va
repartir les gens sont heureux de sortir
consommer des produits locaux aussi
c'est vrai que les gens sont venus sur
les produits locaux et c'est vraiment
génial et donc je pense que pour pour la
bière ça présage que du bon pour
l'avenir